vous et moi
jacques est en train de me [ __ ] à
l'émission tu t'es point tu te casses
comme ça tu me fout en l'air mon
émission autorités invitaient c'est des
questions c'est vraiment c'est terrible
et si tu me connais tu sais mais je pose
déjà bien en quoi pain et puis d'un seul
coup c'est c'est un piège dans des raids
a jamais vu mes émissions et non mais
pour les autres vous et vous connaissez
ces différences quand même je sais pas
on est sur la même chaîne
sur la même chaîne fera étape sur les
autres mais enfin là je suis ça va aller
quoique estime que je m'excuse ok moi je
m'excuse
voilà un gentil ok je te prie de
m'excuser et non pas comme ça ça s'est
joué
je veux je te prie non simplement comme
tu le ferais pour un soir où tu rentré
très tard et où je dis à ta femme j'ai
été retenu par la télévision
j'étais retenu pour la télévision excuse
moi avoue quand même que t'es pas facile
à vivre
c'est normal notre métier c'est pour ça
que tu as été mariée trois fois non non
non c'est pas comme ça que j'ai été
mariée trois fois c'est elle qui
l'envoie eu la patience on se dit les
femmes sont de plus tant d'ennemis ah
oui c'est vrai ce sont autant
ouais tu n'as pas d'expérience ben j'ai
souffert humant favre tu avais la montre
mes blessures c'est un regard françoise
ici c'est alicia dans le dos rien quelle
horreur d'anciens combattants taylor
d'avoir beaucoup souffert quand même à
oui ça se voit et en ce qui concerne ton
précédent livre tu as dit le temps passe
mais je ne pardonne pas oui à quelques
faux je pardonne pas là t'as pas de
calais tess celui d'avant là le
printemps dernier et dernière séparation
sadi ne tend pas tu m'étonnes écoute on
en fait tout un plat mais enfin je me
suis mariée deux fois c'est le moindre
mal et céline tu vas d'épouser ça c'est
mon petit jardin
ah c'est vrai que tu l'a rencontrée sur
le plateau du monde est à vous oui ça
s'est passé comment
o le plus simplement du monde on s'est
rencontré sur un plateau un jour tous
les deux oui enfin on a bien fait passer
par ici on sait pas comment ça ce sera
terminé quand elle avait ce qui se passe
ce soir
dis moi tu es dit céline m'a réconcilié
avec les femmes alors c'est vrai parce
qu'elle est boussu bien parce qu'elle
m'a apporté beaucoup de choses que je
n'avais jamais si tu dis ça à chaque
fois non mais non à chaque fois c'est
différent vous avez fait chaque fois je
vais finir par passer pour barclays ont
débarqué en deux phases j'aimerais bien
tu verras tu vois tes ex élève nous par
exemple la revoir elle est
incontournable aux étudiants la
rencontre de partage est ce que tu vas
aller au salon du divorce
oui ça m'amuse rageant travers un sketch
les bars regarde le salon